hey it's justine and today's video is
going to be a little bit different than
my usual videos but it is going to be
very exciting if you're someone in the
corporate world who's looking for a pc
for yourself your business or outfitting
your company's employees now that's not
to say that these can't be used by
everyone but i partnered with hp to
showcase this lineup in a way that
highlights the best use cases for the
corporate world we'll be focusing on
security sustainability and the software
plus the design and specs of them all
let's get into it thanks hp for
sponsoring this video and providing
these devices to show you guys this
current lineup that might fit your needs
we're going to be unboxing and covering
four devices today the hb pro book x360
435 the hp elitebook 845 the hp pro book
445 and the hp pro book 635 aero g7
that's a lot of devices for one video so
i hope you guys are sitting down and
have a snack or two maybe get a whole
meal the first one that we have is the
hp pro book x360 435 g7 that is the full
name and we're about to unbox it so
let's let's get into it i kind of
already
opened it up and took a little peek
power supply
and computer
oh this is actually a lot smaller and
thinner than i thought and it's also
super light
all right here's a first look
oh yeah i'm ready to type oh this has a
fingerprint sensor on it as well so this
is the hp pro book x360 435 g7 and what
i love about this is the fact that this
has a 360 degree hinge so this allows
the user to really choose how they want
to use this in any situation especially
for businesses this is really great for
presentations you can just flip the
display over and
you're ready to go and you know what
else this is really good for other than
works it's great for watching movies or
tv shows whatever you want and then you
can get back to work i love that this is
a touch screen and it can also act as a
two in one so if i want to turn this
into a tablet i can so this makes things
like giving presentations or watching
content or making some podcast notes so
that my sister and i have something to
look at while we're doing our podcast
very easily this is great
lots of stuff to talk about in the next
episode of the podcast jenna coffey tech
maddy more maddie maddie the dog pets
cute dogs tech this is some business
getting done right here guys a lot of
these laptops can be customized with
different things this one for example
you can also get it with dual cameras so
this does have one camera up here on the
display they also have an option if you
want to get another camera in the
keyboard so if you're in tablet mode
you'll be able to take photos no matter
how you're holding the device this one
actually doesn't have the dual cameras
in it but just knowing that that's an
option if you do want it is pretty cool
it also has a fingerprint sensor which
is another optional feature i'm such a
huge fan of having fingerprint sensors
on my computer it's something that i've
become very used to so the fact that
this does have this also built in is
another really great security feature as
for performance you get a choice of the
latest amd ryzen 4000 quad 6 or 8 core
processors there's a long lasting
battery life with hp fast charge which
will get you to 50
in 30 minutes now security is obviously
a huge concern no matter who you are
with a fear of firmware attacks that can
completely destroy your pc this has hp
sure start for amd which is a
self-healing bios that automatically
recovers from attacks without having to
do anything like it just does it
automatically for you the hp pro pen
also lets you write draw and take notes
on the screen in addition to your
business work this could also be a great
addition for kids doing their online
classes and taking notes or just drawing
and having fun i know i honestly can't
even imagine going back to school right
now i'd be so hyped up to take notes all
day on all of these amazing devices that
are out there this keyboard is spill
resistant which also makes it very easy
to disinfect with various types of wipes
now i can't tell you how many times i've
spilled drinks on my laptop and i know
i'm not alone this is running windows 10
with a 2.7 gigahertz amd ryzen processor
8 gigs of ram a 256 gig solid-state
drive and display is 13.3 inches it also
has a micro sd card expansion slot and
weighs about three 3.19 pounds like it's
super light here's our micro sd card
slots our headphone port
hdmi usb a usbc and a power port and on
the other side we have another usb-a you
can never have enough usb ports
next up is hp elitebook 845 g7 this one
i did not take a peek in so
join me
for the unboxing
this is a nice cable
look at that
oh my gosh this is honestly
i
kid you not i think this is my favorite
power adapter to date for any computer
ever look at this it's like a braided
soft cable
oh
my gosh
how cool
oh this is also super light one of the
things that i've liked so far is how
light these are portability is something
that's really important i think
especially if well basically for anybody
that has a laptop but
this
is so light and this one has the new hp
logo on it it's just i don't know what
it is it's just perfect
i mean look at this
like that logo just makes everything
look so cool this is cool this is cool
oh
okay this is look at this this has like
a little
it's not a joystick but does that have a
special name this has such an awesome
look to it i mean the speakers they even
kind of have them etched in like this
really nice design oh it has the
anti-reflective screen so these have
bang olufsen speakers i love the little
design that they have on the keyboard
layout it makes it look really cool
let's pump up this really chill jam
[Music]
so here it is and some of the main
highlights other than of course the
performance is the design this is highly
secure super thin and very light it has
an all-day battery life up to 26 hours
which is the world's longest battery
life in an amd-based mainstream business
notebook can you guys say that five
times fast
world's longest battery life in an amd
based mainstream business notebook
you get the point this is also the first
time that amd processors are available
in elitebook this features amd's ryzen
pro processor with radeon vega graphics
a new redesigned keyboard that has a
really quiet typing
you guys well i mean of course you hear
it but it's way more quiet than previous
models
this will come in handy if we ever
actually go back to offices i know some
people have returned to work if you are
in an office with a lot of different
people the more people typing on their
keyboards the louder that's going to be
so any way that you can reduce keyboard
clicking is definitely a plus in my book
and my book is digital so you can find
it on
any word that you get books
[Music]
it has this really cool keyboard based
power button that you can program with a
hotkey so all of your apps will launch
at once for me this is huge because
whenever i'm about to do a live stream
or something like that like there's a
bunch of different apps that go into
this so being able to just press a
button
right there on the keyboard and
everything that i have set up will
automatically launch that's gonna save
me i mean probably not like that much
time but i mean like if you you know in
the long run if you think about this
over the course of years it's gonna save
you time and there's nothing that i love
more than saving time maybe some key
into your cookies that could maybe rival
that it's debatable now this is a
feature that i'm obsessed with hp sure
is an integrated privacy screen so if
people are next to you this will help
conceal your screen at a side angle view
check this out okay i will make how
about a spreadsheet on how many snacks i
eat a day
i don't want to lie to you guys i don't
have anything in my cup
so this is hp short view this is a
privacy screen and basically you just
push a button and automatically your
screen dims
to this copper color so you're not able
to see from the side
and when i turn my screen to you guys
you're able to see it
isn't that crazy
i really wish that this was a feature in
every computer because there's a lot of
times that i'm working on projects that
are super secret or i'm editing a photo
of myself for instagram and i don't want
the people in the airplane to see what
i'm doing and ask me questions i also
used to always work at coffee shops and
on flights and even in places where my
screen is very visible so this is really
cool
i love it this is one of the only hp
laptops that come with hp work well
integrated into it this is designed to
coach you to take breaks exercise and
give you productivity tips personalized
to you if only it could
lift up my limbs and pick up the weights
for me
then
we'd be in business but until then i
mean i guess at that point then we would
be robots and
i don't even know if we need a computer
because we are one this has 16 gigs of
ram 256 gigs of storage a ryzen r7 pro
4700u processor 14-inch full hd display
with a built-in hd and ir camera with
wide viewing angle so here's the ports
on this one we've got two usb-a's we got
a headphone jack and on the other side
we have actually two usb-c ports an hdmi
and our power adapter again a lot of
these laptops are customizable so i'll
put links in the description where you
can check them all out and see
everything that you can customize in
each one but now
guess what
we have another computer to look at
next up we have the hp pro book 445 g7
this one this one looks a little bigger
than a previous i should probably use an
axe to open this
[Music]
oh yeah look at you
power adapter
[Music]
tada
this is cool
this has a little privacy slide all you
have to do is slide it right over there
to the left and your camera is hidden
one of the things that i see people
doing is they're putting tape over top
of their webcams and this is not good
for a bunch of reasons first of all you
could potentially be damaging the area
around your camera the screen and when
you close your laptops that piece of
tape is then making your laptop a little
bit thicker so it can start ruining
things so it's not the best idea ever i
mean if you're doing that right now like
i mean you probably you probably
shouldn't that's why this is a really
great idea and it's all flushed right
there to the web oh this is nice this is
cool so this is the hp pro book 445 g7
notebook this is thin it's light and it
has a lot of really great commercial
features that companies are looking for
at a very affordable price this is also
extremely adorable this has a 180 degree
hinge so there's a little bit more of a
hinge but not quite the 360 like we've
seen in the previous one
look how flat this gets
like it feels like this is something
that
you shouldn't be able to do but you can
i've always wanted to do this on a
laptop just completely take the entire
top
and just go like that most of them
usually stop you and it also has six
gigs of ram a two gigahertz eight core
amd ryzen 7 4000 processor 512 gig ssd
14 inch anti-glare display which you can
see right here i love displays that have
anti-glare i always do find myself
working in various places coffee shops
or in studios like this with bright
lights so carrying this over to offices
where a lot of people are usually
working by windows or different types of
overhead lighting this helps out
immensely this also has an amd radeon
graphics card sd card slot a 720p hd ir
camera spill resistant keyboard and a
very long lasting battery life with hp
fast charge i know we keep talking about
security but this is such a huge concern
especially with everyone's businesses
and so much sensitive information that's
stored on our laptops this has
commercial grade security features
enhanced from the bios up but justine
what are those someone off in the
distance asks well i'm glad that you did
ask because i was going to tell you
anyway hp surestart gen 5 is the first
that allows for self-healing bios that
will automatically recover itself from
attacks i talked about this before
basically if your firmware is attacked
or your computer is compromised this
will automatically heal itself and you
guys don't have to do anything i did
mention the privacy camera this is a
physical shutter that you can slide over
so it will protect you when it's not in
use hp sure view gen 3 will instantly
block the ability to see your screen
with the optional hp sure view gen 3
that reduces visual glare when it's
viewed from the side making your screen
appear darker and unreadable these are
some really great added features all in
this one laptop which really does make
it a great choice for someone looking
for a pc with all of these added
security options and just like the
others this also has an optional
fingerprint sensor so much security so
little time
all right
three down
one to go
this is the hp pro book 635 aero g7
let's unbox
power cable
rest of the power cable
oh this is light
oh look at you
oh wow this is super light
i can't believe how light this is
i just still am such a huge fan of the
fingerprint sensor we have two usb ports
and we also have audio right there the
other side we've got hdmi out and also a
usb c port and this is for the power and
this is for the nano sim because this
does support 4g lte so the hp pro book
635 aero g7 is truly a device that is
geared towards someone who needs a
powerful pc and also have the option to
constantly stay connected with support
for 4g lte while being one of the
lightest amd-based business notebooks it
definitely doesn't skimp on internals it
has a 13.3 inch full hd display amd
ryzen 4000 series processor and up to
one terabyte of solid state storage 32
gigs of ram wi-fi 6 plus it's really
light and super durable this has an
option for anti-glare screen with ultra
thin bezels and has a new keyboard for
quiet typing and an hp programmable key
this only webcam has an 88 degree wide
field of view so you'll be able to fit
so much more into your screen this has a
ton of options so you can fully
customize it to your needs or the needs
of your employees thank you guys so much
for watching i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and a little look at some of
the enterprise options that hp has to
offer i'll put a link in the description
if you guys want to check it out and i
will see you guys in my next video bye
[Music]